blake shelton is reacting to rumors that
ariana grande is set to replace him on
the voice
i'm the one that gets ganged up on check
out this screenshot ari shared on
instagram blake texted the thank you
next singer a link to a tabloid report
that says ari's energy on the show means
the country crooner is getting the boot
blake's response thanks a lot ari thanks
a [ __ ] lot
i feel your love every day clearly
ariana thought it was hilarious you'll
see she added heart reactions to both
texts
it's the most fun i've ever had in my
whole life but it's not the first time
the singers have playfully poked fun at
one another on social media shortly
after the season 21 premiere ariana
posted this a slightly altered clip from
mean girls to her instagram page
do not trust her
she is a
fugly [ __ ]
[Music]
blake saw the clip and commented okay
little buddy this is war
so i guess i still have it gossip
reports aside the 28 year old singer has
been fitting in super well with her
fellow season 21 coaches including
shelton john legend and kelly clarkson
i'm grateful
but there's no denying it's stiff
competition among the coaches here's
what they told et about the pop star
joining them this season and coming in
strong for a team ari win
of course she's a threat yeah of course
she's a threat she is hugely talented
hugely successful and has legions and
legions of fans that know how to use the
internet and vote
we always come out like you know in like
like i'll go john goes whatever and
blake's usually laughs he gets the most
screams and and and well
and then he used to he used to you too
and then all of a sudden he was like can
ariana go before me because they lose
their mind
it's embarrassing to follow her but
that's why we enjoy it see we wanted it
to stay that way because we enjoyed
the problem
exposes
my lack of celebrity celebrities
when ariana goes in front of a celebrity
yeah i think i have a hearing problem
what are your fan clubbers called uh
my fans literally don't even have a name
but
there aren't any i was a huge fan of the
voice i have watched many seasons and i
love watching the show it always has the
best energy and it's just such like
wholesome inspiring television and i
love seeing the different voices and
watching so many people start careers
for themselves it's like a beautiful
amazing thing
you